[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled efficient reliable and
comprehensive solution for cgt from
Target Discovery to clinical development
this webinar is a part of the fifth
annual event in the bioprocessing
virtual event series I am Shelley Mulock
of labroots and I'll be your moderator
for today's
evental web seminar is presented by
labroots and sponsored by gen script for
more information about gen script go to
jscript.dll
using our live chat feature during the
presentation you can find the live chat
located at the left of your screen you
can also participate by submitting as
many questions as you would like during
the presentation to do so simply type
them into the ask a question box and
click submit we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the
presentation you will also notice that
the speaker has provided a survey
located to the right of the abstract
this survey will be available during
both the live session and the on demand
period if you have trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation click on the
help desk button located at the top
within the navigation bar or from the
lobby finally as a reminder this
presentation is educational and offers
free continuing education credits click
on the continuing education credits link
located in the abstract window below the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits I now
present today's speaker Dr doc shapel
senior segment marketing manager Cell
Therapy genscript USA Incorporated for a
complete biography on our speaker please
visit the present the presenter tab from
the menu at the top left of your screen
Dr D shatel you may now begin your
presentation
good morning good afternoon everyone and
welcome to my presentation first of all
let me thank all of you for coming here
today and today I'm going to give you
brief overview about the Gen script cell
and gene therapy
solution for today's presentation the
subjects can be looked under the
following heading in my presentation I
will focus on Cell Therapy development
and gene therapy development and how gen
script can support from Discovery to
development
Journey let me start by sharing some
background information about the company
gen script is a biotech company that
provides life and service and product
worldwide and last year gen script
celebrated 20th Cent uh 20th anniversary
and the company was founded in 2002 and
its headquarter is in New Jersey and
location is in China Europe and Japan in
2002 launch the first custom Gene
synthesis service and in 2013 gen script
launched the new company sorry
subsidiary company based enzyme in which
is providing the synthetic biology
products in 2014 launch Legend B legend
biotic which is a subsidiary company
specialized in cell therapy in 2019 la
launch gen script
proo uh which is a specialized cdmo
service provider and
2021 it's open its new location and
facility in Singapore and Shanghai and
Us in 20122 lean Carell therapy this get
approval from
FDA so gen script life science offer a
wide range of service and product to
support the life science research drug
Discovery and development service
include the Gene and peptide synthesis
custom antibody development and
production protein purification and
expression and molecular biology
reagents in recent year gen script
launched its service in cell and gen
therapy area also for cell engine
therapy Discovery and development uh
genin script is providing the custom
plasmid viral Vector cell line
engineering and cell separation reagents
and
equipment so after the brief
introduction about the company I next I
would like to give you some overview of
the cell therapy field history and
current
status the first observation that immune
system plays a role in the anti-tumor
activity is attributed by Dr kohi in 18
90 after that it took almost Century to
make the cell therapy as essential tool
for cancer
treatment in
1985 to 88 tumor INF flating
lymphocytic and cytotoxic T
lymphocyte confirm their therapeutic
potential in 2002 the second generation
of car introduced in the Cell Therapy
field and the creation of the car
molecule Mark A New Beginning in
Innovation uh into the an advancement
into the t- cell therapy area over the
last two decade research on cartis Cell
Therapy is progressing rapidly to
improve the cancer treatment as well as
to expand its use in um more other
cancer type and better managing the
effect of ctis cell
therapy cartis Cel therapy are on be
verge of becoming the potential
immunotherapeutic tool more than 500
carisol therapy and 70 car enk trials
are being conducted worldwide and
including the six products which is get
AA approval and different car generation
are shown in this figure for t- cell
therapy the first generation of car
incorporate the CD3 derived t- Cell
Activation the second generation car
carry the same activate domain but
additionally another one another
stimulating domain added and in third
car generation multiple co- stimulated
domain are incorporated into the
receptor beside the modification of the
second generation car more advanced car
immune cell Therapeutics are being
tested which utilize the precise
insertion of gene into the to avoid the
graft versus host disease in addition C
cell with armor
proteins uh expression is under
development which typically enhance the
t- cell function and favorably modify
the tumor micro
environment so here I represent the cell
therapy workflow and the cell therapy
work process divided into the three Area
Discovery development commercial
Manufacturing in Gene and t- cell
therapy the introduction of Gene could
either be invivo or xvivo um in uh case
of cartis therapy but most importantly
the Target responsible for the genetic
disease or the cancer antigen for the
carticel therapy has to be identified
subsequently lead optimization is
required to determine the Affinity of
cancer antigen and beta cytotoxic effect
finally with validation and success in
the preclinical trial many such cell and
gene therapy required the GMP production
whether you are working or developing
autologous or allergenic imuno Cell
Therapy stem cell therapy or gene
therapy gen script has solution to help
you to overcome the challenge you face
at each stage of
development after getting the brief
overview of the cell therapy in this
section of presentation I will share
some solution which is provided by Chain
script to support the discovery research
including the target Discovery and lead
generation here represented the
representative workflow for the Target
Discovery and lead generation or
optimization first the patient samples
were collected and using this sequencing
technique and bioinformatic tools
potential Target candidate selected for
further study and potential
lead developing based on Affinity
ranking and then lead can be uh
humanized if it's needed after car
optimization functional essay was
carried out to confirm the toxicity and
bios safety as well as the efficacy
study and as we move ahead next I will
present the Gen script product and
service which can help to do this kind
of
research one of them is the D and oligo
reagents and oligos synthesis
service gen script oligos synthesis
using a semiconductor based
electrochemical oligos synthesis
platform and thousand of sequence are
precisely synthesized simultaneously on
cover sleep size cheap electronic
control of the synthesis process ensure
the top notch sequencing accuracy and
synthesis carried out into the close
environment minimize the exposure to
outside element and giving you us um
minimum variation between the different
pools gen script provide the DNA and RNA
oligo and high throughput oligo pool and
large scale oligo pool synthesis service
and these oligo are widely applicable in
molecular biology molecular diagnosis
including the drug disc discover y Gene
screening and Target
identification so genescript oligos
synthesis platform allow High throughput
synthesis of oligo providing a fast and
economic approach to discovery of disas
Target olop synthesis service off offer
flexible synthesis
capacity high quality oligo and high
sequence in uniformity as well as as
batch to batch
consistency and this
oligo pool can be used to construct the
various Library type one of them is the
crisper G grna Library this fully
customized ready to use grna Library
help high through put screening
including loss of function genetic
screen or transcriptional activate Gene
screening it also helped to understand
the
difficulties and efficiency and
specificity during the crisper gen
editing another one is NGS Target
enrichment Library which helped to
detect the mutation and variant in
genomic DNA occurring within the tumor
and their micro environment it also
helped to
determinate it also helped to
identification of T Cell receptor and
assist to understand patient generic
information enhance personalized
medicine management mutant uh Library
help
in protein and antibody engineering and
allow the complete control of mutation
ratio and create near 100% coverage of
Desire
variant to construct the crisper grna
Library grna are typically clone into
lentil virus Vector for different uh
transduction into the H cell and after
cloning Library are amplify and package
into the viruses and transdance into the
host cell to generate the mutant of cell
clone and the mutant can then be
screened under specific condition such
as a positive or negative to identify
important gene into the
pathway gen script offer the VAR of
library for this purpose one is a
customized grna Library knockout library
transcriptional library and pathway
specific library to have successful
crisper grna Library the quality of grna
is very essential to
design and to design and optimize the
grna AG gen script offer an online G
sgna design tool to make successful
crisper grna
Library High uh quality Precision mutant
Library also offered for various
application mutant Library are powerful
and High throughput um High throughput
uh tools for optimizing the protein
structure and function custom condom Uh
custom codon optimization and cap uh
capabilities are also built in this
platform which allow the researcher do
not only Define the expression
optimization for
particular host organism but incorporate
specific codon and eliminate unwanted
codon in their mutant library for mutant
Library construction individual mutants
are generated by DNA synthesis
technology and then Library are created
using NGS technology and there three
types of PR Precision mutant libraries
are generated sight saturation
saturation scanning and combinational
mutagenesis and this Library can be
delivered as a double uh DNA fragment
form or in the plasmid
form and this figure represent how this
mutant Library help
to uh antibody engineering or screening
process for this process the initial
antibody mutant library is generated
from the corresponding Precision DNA
mutant Library by screening the
mutant and Affinity towards the target
antigen and Bounds antibody are then
eluted and recover for their respected
DNA sequence which can be subsequently
served as a initial pool of the library
and the sequence cycle can be uh
repeated as many times as
needed Gene editing is one of
the essential part in cell and gene
therapy and selecting targets
are frequently validated using the gene
aditing to Sub sub to stimulate the
conduction sorry condition to correct it
Crispers allow a relative way to modify
uh manipulate Gene for gain or loss
function study including the interrupt
insert or remove and this ready to use
gen uh gen crisper
kit simplify the cas Medi Gene editing
it support every steps of Gene editing
workflow including the sgrna a Target
selection sgrna synthesis evaluating the
efficacy of sgrna Gene editing and
mutation efficiency and
detection the chin crisper nucleus also
support the RNA and DNA editing and the
nas plasmids are also good choice for
the easy
use along with that customized cell line
also provided and these cell lines are
different type they may be SS line or
customize s line for cell power or
crisper sin line and all this cell line
can support for evaluation of Target
including the target Gene protein
identification functional research
immunotherapy Discovery and to
understand the binding Affinity of
antibody protein and immunotherapeutic
Target it also support the
cytotoxicity biological activity and
biochemical mechanism and of Target
evaluation and 100 of saline deliver and
used by researcher for various
application and cited in many
publication along with that the antibody
is also a very essential research tool
in scientific field and help researcher
to identify and quantify their protein
targets including the protein
localization
protein expression and interaction of
protein detection as well as the cell
analysis for many application gen script
offer of Target antibody products but
sometimes researchers study on new dises
and mechanism and may be they can they
can't find the suitable antibody for the
application and CH script provide the
customized antibody service to support
the new disease and the new Target
research with two platform uh one is a B
cell cloning platform which has a high
diversity and high success rate and beon
uh single Bell High throughput platform
uh which allow to do isolation screening
and evaluation of antibody within a one
day and this what platform are useful
for generating the custom antibody for
development and monitoring the C cell
therapy and it's also used for customiz
development and therapeutic
Discovery and this two platform can make
different kind of antibody including the
plon clonal anti monoclonal antibody uh
sdme generation or SCF and VHS
generation as well as by specific
antibody
generation uh expressing the recombinant
antibody in Maman shell is essential
when post transational alternation and
proper folding are required for
Downstream
application and to support the protein
expression service gen script launched
the turbo um CH platform offering the
higher ELD performance within the
shorter period and thus the cost
effective production s and uh possible
to create create by using this turbo Jo
platform uh along with that gen script
also providing the free Cordon
optimization tools which facilate the
gene sequencing to obtain the functional
antibody through tboo
platform high throughput eoli platform
and expression service also offered and
which is uh very useful for the
recombinant proteins such as the cyto
kind enzyme immun and antibody fragment
generation Target engagement and
antibody of biomarker help to understand
the relationship between the uh genotype
and the phenotype and SBA page and
Western blotting are the most commonly
used technique yet difficult to get the
persistence and obtaining the uh
consistent quality
results for that we providing full range
of High Performance Tools including the
pre-cast gel uh protein transfer system
gel staining system automated Wern
floting system and also provide the
protein and antibody purification
automat system M sa+ which use the
magnetic bit technology to purifying the
protein and antibody and gen script also
providing the bright uh broad range of
high quality primary and secondary antib
body such as a anti-ed imuno che or
antibody conjugation service and all
these primary antibody are validated for
different application including the
Alisa or Western blood vhh is also one
of the promising tool in the therapeutic
and developing the ctis cell therapy and
conjugation and labeling antibody also
use for various application including
the cell analysis using the
facts
neoantigen Target T Cell Therapy is a
promising approach to cancer treatment
and but it's still in the early stage of
development research is ongoing to
improve the identification and targeting
of Neo antigen and optimize the
production and delivery of modified T
Cell new antigen are unique protein that
are produced by cancer cell due to the
mutation of the DNA and to create the
neoantigen targeted T Cell Therapy
researcher first need to identify the
neoantigen expressed by the patient
cancer cell this can be done by
analyzing the patient tumor DNA and RNA
and then using the comput
algorithm predict which neoantigen most
likely to be recognized by T Cell once
the Neo antigen have been identified T
cell is olated and then it's undergo
engineer gen um T Cell Engineering
Process and then modified T cells can be
insert back to the patient so here I
represent the representative diagram how
the new antigen P cell therapy works and
new antigen
peptides uh workflow shown next to this
therapy worklow so here the ne antigen
pepti is produced into the CH scrape uh
shows here and peptide can be used for
various application including the imuno
sorry imuno genicity testing and
screening clinical stage vaccine
development and postclinical
efficacy study
also and gen script has providing
reliable peptide from last 18 years with
her prop Pro priority microwave assisted
um peptide synthesis platform now able
to deliver the high quality peptide in
within the five days custom peptide
synthesis service also available and we
are providing different kind of peptides
quality fast peptide which are suitable
for targets
identification and basic peptide which
are ideal for immuno immune monitoring
and T Cell epitope mapping and premium
Pro peptide service also
available uh we also offer the free
online peptide Library design tools
which help the to generate the different
peptide Library based on your
application and peptide Library allowing
scientists to identify the most
important peptide for binding
interaction quickly for example in case
of t- cell application for cancer uh
libraries have been used to identify
specific lion which can recognize the
tumor cell and to meet the different uh
Purity demand for multiple application
we develop the two different type of
pepti Library one is a standard peptide
Library which is available
in high Purity and the microscale
peptide Library which is ideal for
preliminary
screening and
application overall gen script is
offering wide range of products and
service for Target Discovery and Target
identification uh genetic Association
protein expression functional screening
and genetic manipulation of Target can
be uh identify or can be discovered by
using all these different tools which
transcript is
providing uh in this section we will
share more detailed information about
the transcript solution for cell
isolation activation and
expansion so Cell Therapy are an
emerging treatment option for wide
variety of disease and most Cell Therapy
involveed the cell isolation in
laboratory setting for cell therapy uh
drug Discovery
research and in core facility as the
part of the cell manufacturing as well
as cell banking
workflow um the cell isolation reagents
are essential further more manufacturing
high quality consistent and efficient
Cell Therapy product depend on obtaining
high quality reagents from established
manufacturing partner with supply chain
security genscript has developed the
cytosin reagent and consumable
including automated platform system
which gives the high Purity High
recovery and functional viable cell to
support the cell therapy
workflow so here I present the cytosin
equipment which is a cell isolation
equipment and work on basis of
immunomagnetic cell isolation concept
it's automated instruments and uh it has
the key highlight features is include
easily accessible barcode scanning for
agent entry customizable programming uh
fully traceable uh traceability means we
can trace the whole process and from the
uh during the manufacturing workflow as
well as it's allow the workflow exit
situation means uh with workflow screen
provide uh real time monitoring and it's
walkway solution and it is providing two
different type of tubing set one is from
the isolation another one for the
depletion and within the isolation there
is a two different type of tubing set
which giving you allow to uh purify two
different number of cell starting from 6
into 10 to 10 versus 1 to 10 to
10 and cytoc platform and reents unable
researcher to scale up their operation
and can be
easily uh integrated with other
instrument and platform for all
necessary processing step including the
sample washing labeling magnetic
separation and cell
concentration so this is representative
workflow and it's well suit for the
modular system and these reagents are
efficient sterilized non-toxic and easy
to
use here represented uh uh one
representative data for using the
cyto Thousand equipment well cell are
isolated using U cytosin equipment along
with the control experiments carried out
with the another instrument which is
available in market and if you see here
the datas are shown into
this slides where cell viability are not
effect after the cell sorting and the
Purity and Recovery are comparable uh
for CD4 and cd8 both cell and working so
cyto th000 equipment working very well
in terms of Purity recovery and
viability and cytosin manual uh SE
separation systems allowed flexible and
convenient option for large to small
scale uh
separation so this one um used for the
research work purpose and we are
providing different cell isolation ready
to use reagent they are available in Aro
grade as well as GMP grade including CD4
cd8 CD3 and nksl isolation as well as
TCR alpab beta nanobits we also
providing the step dividin beads along
with the uh biotinilated antibody and T
Cell Activation
reagents so here we presented some
comparison data for pre and post
isolation from leukopheresis using
transcript uh um
reagents and we used the another compor
reents as a control and Purity and
recovery of CD4 and and CD3 in both the
cases looks quite promising including
their performance is matching with the
control
samples and this reagent can uh also be
used for the depletion purpose and here
representated CD4 depletion using the
human CD4 cytosin nanobit and it it
depleted CD4 cell by
99.9% and it's showing very similar data
as the control C
and now I'm talking about the T Cell
Activation reagents so gen script T Cell
Activation reagents is uniform
biocompatible and non-toxic cd28 cd23
couple uh antibody couple nanobits which
allow the feder cell free and antigen
free activation and expansion of t- cell
from pbmc or enr t- cell
population and this is ready to use
reagents are very handy they are small
size and appropriate to use for scalable
application for clinical
manufacturing
so activation Regent study represented
here in this experiment CD4 CDA um cells
are isolated simultaneously and then use
them for Activation purpose
and the figure a represent the
expression of the activation marker
after the 48 hours and cell stain with
the fluoresence die after the seven days
it shows the proliferation is happening
so compared to control if you if you see
there is a shift into the fax plot and
then this is the T Cell expansion fold
data which is represented in figure C
and we can see comp the activation NC
Cell Activation reents are data uh
comparable with the control sample and
along with that flow cytometry analysis
of T Cell subpopulation also shown and
they are
also um overall data looks quite
promising uh in this experiment the to T
Cell Activation by using cytosin uh CD3
nanobit purified T cell is used as a
static material and the figure a
represent the expression of c um
activation marker and then figure B
represent the higher full expansion is
observed and then figure D represent the
T Cell sub population so same Trend we
can see as the previous experiments in
by using the ncel activation reation and
this is confirming that NCS desel
activation reagents giving very uh good
results for the expansion sorry
activation and then expansion is also a
very
good enal en enrichment carried out by
two method one is
cd56 uh direct selection without any
kind of depletion and the Purity and
Recovery represented here and the
control sample and the cytosin cd56
Beards performance are very well and
then t uh andk cell enrichment also
carried out after the CD3 depletion so
overall uh all the reagents Performing
very well and different application and
different
platform uh and this U gen script is are
alpha beta beads these beads support the
onstop isolation process so by direct
labeling need only one reagent which is
antibody couples particle available so
anti TCR alpab beta antibody couple on
the particle surface and the advantage
is like easy to use in the bigger scale
Means Auto scale as well as it's a
simple one-step process while other
reents which is available in the market
they are indirect labeling so first you
uh need to label the cell with the
antibiotic antibody and then wash the
excess of antibody and then add the
biotin level antibody and Sav particles
required for magnetic
isolation and these are the preliminary
data so TCR alpab beta be directly
labeling is also performing very well
uh and this be has a many many Advantage
because it's only using single
leveling so cytosin and growth factor
also one of the essential uh reagents
and in T Cell Therapy required the
growth factor to expand which are
provided by the using the media or by
the serum and one of the useful growth
factor is il2 which is binding in
receptor and promote the T Cel expansion
so gen scripts offer the comprehensive
catalog recombinant protein and cyto
kindes and with the lot to lot
consistency and this can be used for
various application like for the immune
cell culturing stem cell culturing and
even they can be used in the cyto
therapy so more than 2,000 cytokines
growth factor and peptides for cell
therapy research are also available and
we also provide them to the custom
synthesis
service
after getting information about the cell
isolation activation in this section I
will give more detailed information
about the cell engineering and uh gene
therapy uh platform including the viral
uh gene therapy and non-viral um gene
therapy platforms which genescript is
providing so before presenting the
genescript cell engineering product and
service I briefly introduced the tel
engineering progress and in Carell
therapy Tel engineering is the essential
to obtain the efficient tumor killing um
property and originally the viral Vector
have been used for ctis cell
manufacturing however the random Gene
integration introduce immunogenicity
risk associated with it and later on
crisper te T Cell uh engine uh crisper T
Cell use along with the adenovirus
vector to deliver the DNA payload for
Target insertion via HDR temp template
into TCR but despite of its good
performance and high editing efficiency
uh limited Vector capacity and high
manufacturing cost it's restrict the
viral engineering workflow and currently
nonviral crisper editing
providing an alternative tools
for Gene insertion and the first car
crisper based therapy phase clinical
study is also a complete
and to support this the development of
crisper genome editing open the new
possibility in P Precision medicine
currently uh there are n number of
research is under Pro progress including
the blood blood disorder cancer or
diabetes infection disease um and
protein binding disorder and number of
crisper clinical trial is on uh is under
progress and it's going very fast day by
day so to support ongoing demand for
nonviral system genscript offered the
wide range of reation to support the
discovery work and we already dis uh
discuss about all these reagents in the
discovery stage uh portfolio but along
with that transcript offer the
rnp including the synthesis s grna and
cine protein and DNA payload and donor
templates including the SS DNA stable SS
DS DNA and Gene Circle DS uh Gene Circle
D uh
dsdna uh Crystal based Gene editing
application moving from basic research
to clinical manufacturing high quality
raw materials and combin uh along with
the complete documentation are becoming
more essential to fulfill high
quality um specification a GMP gr GMP
grade gin crisper Ultra case 9 service
also offered we offer two type S9 and
key highlights of this reagent it's
providing High dating efficiency High
lot to lot consistency ultra high
stability and high quality
specification in this figure it shows
that T Cell uh receptor Alpha Beta chain
knockout efficiency was measured and
analyzed by the FES using the GMP grade
G9 system and of Target efficiency also
measured into two different platform uh
OT ot1 and ot2 andin crisper um C9
Source low of Target
efficiency uh J uh we also providing to
sgrna service line uh the first one is
the easy edit
sgrna and this sgrna is excellent option
for crisper screen and significant
benefit of service are highlighted here
because it's ready to you and ensures
High knockout efficiency another one is
a safe edit sgrna and these are the hlc
purify and so uh this service line is
ideal for gene therapy application as
well as using crisper in animal mod
animal model and the main benefit of our
safe um Gene edity is high Purity sgrna
with modification ensuring the minimum
cytotoxicity and of Target for primary
cell and stem
cell so as mentioned in the previous
Slide the main benefit of our uh safe
edit sgna include High Purity so here is
represented like it's showing
99% uh High uh Purity compared to the
commercially available other sgna and
hlc purification remove the presence of
unwanted or trunk
sgna and which can reduce the of Target
effect so purity of gen script shown
here is 99% which is very high compared
to others reg
agent uh one another powerful
application of crisper C9 Chom editing
technology involveed the DNA sequence
via um HDR pathway and many factors may
affect the efficacy of this approach
and choosing of the suitable HDR
template is
the uh essential and genscript offer the
high quality sequence verified HDR
template including the gene extract
ssdna Gene V DS DNA and Gene Circle DS
DNA they all are available into uh aru
and GMP like and each of them have a
different insertion length
capacity
uh with advancement in the crisper cas9
technology it is now possible to insert
the target Gene sequence at the specific
genomic site in primary human primary t-
cells for car expression without using
the viral Vector so in this case study
Dr Brian developed a hybrid single
standard DNA ssdna hdrt with
CTS and the diagram of this
hybrid SSD and HDT shown here and the
study was conducted at the mar uh
markenson Lab at
UCSF uh due to the challenge in the
production of the Lang long ssdna
sequence in the lab Dr Brian
collaborated with transcript and were
able to perform therapeutic Gene editing
on primary t- cell at clinical stage
using gen script
ssdna
and the results shown um so in this um
slides I present the few data of that
experiments so figure a represent the
diagram of nonviral cartis cell
manufacturing process they use and the
result shows that transcript
sctc Co consistence H performs better
compared to the uh lab generated SSC and
ssdna which is represented in figure b c
and d and The Knockout efficiency in gen
script SS um CTC via electroporation
without enhance enhancer can reach up to
2% at clinical scale means on this scale
and the KN knock in positive live cell
count generated by the CH script associ
was above estimated patient do and in
vitro assay demon the eff efficiency of
killing BCM a car cell is shown in this
graph G so hence the Dr Brian from Mark
marson's lab um developed the novel
payload for nonviral approach to Gene
editing and it's applicable in clinical
scale to support the GMP compatible
nonviral cartis cell manufacturing using
genin script
ssdna uh Gene Circle sis DNA is also a
noble small circular double standard DNA
vector and the gene Circle sess DNA
include um the its Advantage is like
it's safer because its antibiotic
resistance CH and bacterial origin
sequence has been removed it's a smaller
and simple so smaller Vector back Bor
um generate the low cytotoxicity and
immunogenicity and
and offer better
stability and it can be used in
application like uh chin Circle
dsdna uh as a Knockin template as well
as viral packaging plasmid and GOI
nonviral Vector overall more efficient
um uh Gene Circle DS DNA
uh can be offered from gen script into
different uh um Quality
and this can be very useful for Gene and
cell therapy
study here we have data comparing the
gene Circle DS DNA Vector compared to
the traditional plasmid and as we can
see HDR knocking efficiency is
significantly higher with chain Circle
template it's about
30% um improve compared to the standard
plasmid and low cytotoxic it is also
observed and hence U this performing
very well where Mean Gene editing can be
Advanced into cell and gene therapy
using gene Circle DS
DNA mRNA is also now becoming new
therapeutic approach for range of disase
and simplify cellfree manufacturing cell
cycle independent performance and risk
free in insertion of the mutagenesis
increase the IBT mRNA adaptability into
the therapeutic field gen script
solution to mRNA production start from
the gene synthesis to ivt mRNA
production as shown here and to
simplify um to simple and Innovative
mRNA manufacturing
workflow uh offer uh
more opportunity for personalized
medicine use and mRNA Pro produce are
optimized with the pro priority Pro
priority platform um ensuring the
equality and expression
efficiency custom mRNA service also
available um sorry custom mRNA service
also available
and they are three different type of
mRNA we are
providing and this here represented the
MRNA mediated delivery of cast
9 has certain Advantage it's efficient
and there is no genomic interference
happening and it's providing High
editing efficiency and potential low of
Target rate so here shows the
preliminary data where G 9 mRNA used
for the same purpose and as shown in the
figure mRNA
Integrity uh impact its
expression and so high integrity support
the high expression for C9 mRNA system
and this version of C9 nucleus reduce
the of Target effect by over 10 full and
while maintaining the robust On Target
genome editing efficiency so mRNA
products including Gene editing
mRNA uh
Sleeping Beauty mRNA and reporter Gene
mRNA also
available so as a leading Cell Therapy
nucleic acid provider we believe in
support the life uh support the future
of nonviral gene therapy and providing
all different grade reg agents for
Discovery to clinical application and
there are different qu
are mention like for R&D grade process
development and clinical manufacturing
grade available for nonviral Gene
editing as well as gene therapy
purpose we also providing the third
generation uh lentil virus packaging to
um ensure the
downstream
safety uh for cgt
application uh difference between the
two generations shown in this table so
the and the full spectrum of service
available from uh for llv and op so
that's including like optimization of
viral product production to obtain the
maximum yield and intact functional
viral Vector with high transduction
efficiency and multiple Tighter and QC
methods to confir the consistent
quality and uh lentil virus Eliza kits
also
designed to measure the physical tier
and it makes lentil while titration easy
accurate and
responsi uh sorry reproducible and this
kit can be very useful tools for routine
quality uh control and lot to lot
release and purification purpose
optimization along with the lentil virus
packaging service we also providing the
AV Packaging service and all these can
be used for The Knockout screen Sal
engineering and therapeutic Gene
delivery uh gen script probo is a cdmo
service
uh uh Pro it's providing the C service
for cgt application and all the
customized uh um option available and
the the most
common um used material inine therapy de
velopment and sell therapy development
is plasmid so it's also the Gen scrip
probo providing the service for plasmid
of any size for various application so
it's including the GMP plasmid
production in different quality and pro
and also like service accommodate the
both the small scale as well as the
large scale
requirement similarly lentil viral
Vector is also a useful vehicle to
deliver the chin and uh into the cell
engine therapy area and uh the safety
and stable manufacturing of llv is very
essential so gen script is provide um
gen Script probo support the developing
both the um adance and suspension
platform to delivering and Manufacturing
the lentil viral Vector a vector is also
a most widely used as a vehicle in gene
of insertion in Vivo Gene therapy and a
service cover the various need from
research to and IND application to
clinical trial so probo division is
providing all this service customized
service and also providing the car lead
Discovery service and Cy initro essay
study and along with the plasm made uh
manufacturing service we last year
launched the automat IC large scale High
throughput plasmid purification
instrument and along with their
consumable and the M quatro is a fully
automated solution for purifying the
large scale high quality plasmid and the
comprehensive um solution consist a
System Controller that provide the
simultaneously operation of up to four
independent purification module uh the M
qu
powered by magnetic be technology and
the key benefit is allowed the height
throughput up to 24 sample and fle
flexible uh volume ranging from 50 to
200 mL and ready to use consumable
available for
that so jrip biotech uh premium
convenient and reliable service and
product used by number of researcher and
scientist worldwide and more than 74,000
peer reviews Journal articles uh have
been cited gen script biotech service
and
product so this bring me to end my
presentation and in summarize my main
points uh covered is like we offering
end to end solution to
accelerate um Journey from Discovery to
clinical research and Commercial
manufacturing by providing the high
quality service reagent and instruments
with scientific and Regulatory support
uh here I show some key reagents which
use both inin and cell therapy and there
different quality available for
different stage from Target Discovery to
lead generation and up to preclinical to
clinical stage so J script offered the
customized option for uh many products
and service
[Music]
is and along with that in this slides I
just to extension the uh service
specifically for cell therapy fi which
include the cell isolation activation
reagents and we also providing the
protein purification and plasma
purification
system so thank you all for your time
and interest and I hope that you find
this useful information if you have any
further question or feedback please
don't hesitate to reach out us and I
will now able to answer any question if
you
have thank
you thank you Dr D Patel for your
informative
presentation we will now start the Q&A
portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now now just click on the ask a question
box located on the far left of your
screen let's get started so Dr Patel the
first question is what tools for car
optimization do you
offer um that's good question so for C T
Cell
Therapy in which generally the T Cell
engineering is very
essential and it's required to make sure
the off Target effect uh is reduced and
enhancing the efficacy we providing like
Precision mutant library and which help
to make the random mutagenesis less
random and it's also allowed to control
the DNA synthesis with semiconductor
technology and this technology will um
give like U it's company's Pro priority
algorith Rhythm design tool can help
researcher to select the um best antigen
binding domain and to uh Co stimulat
domain for the ctis cell as well as
along with the Precision mutant Library
gen smart cond uh codon optimization
tools kit is also a free online tools
which allow
to design the best codon for the ctis
cell um f eacy and targeting efficiency
Improvement along with that DNA
construct design tools that's also a u
very useful to make the uh Library
module for Designing the DNA library and
then create the new multimodel
multi-domain protein or optimize the
protein function or generate the
recombinant protein or antigen and
crisper grna Library also very useful to
screen uh the maximize their e
efficiency of the car uh which is
designed on the cell surface as well as
the gene editing technology may also
help like crisper G9 Gene editing tools
and can enhance by kti
efficacy so overall we are providing
like number of uh customiz uh solution
including like some re agents as well as
services to
design Cy and optimize the efficiency
and specificity of ctis
cell okay wonderful thank you um the
next question is do you see any toxicity
effect of the te- cell activ uh
activation
reagent uh yeah that's a good question
so generally it is necessary to
understand the toxicity effect of Tel
activation reagent but the tel
activation reagent toxicity also effect
on the uh depend on the
concentration uh duration of exposure
and the type of um how long means with
which cell is your starting material uh
but in our company before launching this
reent we did systematic study including
we doing like regular basis of
physiochemical character iation of this
reagent and invitro assay was also
carried out by to understand that Tel
activation the agent has no effect on
Cell viability as well as proliferation
or cyto production and other um relevant
parameter by doing certain type of essay
and we also did Ino essay using the
third party service which include the
safety efficacy and pharmokinetic study
and uh which to meet the Regulatory
Compliance and if you're looking for any
kind of these documents for any stage we
definitely happy to provide that all the
safety data which is um we created in
our company during the launch and after
the launch of this
reagent oh that's very helpful thank you
okay so our next question uh is how long
is the delivery time for the llv
packaging service
and what type of QA are you
providing so for LLB packaging service
we are we have like three different type
of packaging service one is a regular
titter and so uh and another one is a
high title and one is ultra high so uh
basic QC method we providing is Aliza
and microplasma testing but we providing
additional QC testing also like U
sequencing and facts analysis and it
taking mostly 2 to 4 weeks uh for all
this service to deliver and definitely
if you are looking for this kind of
service feel free to reach out we will
make sure you get the
reagents within your time
period excellent okay well it looks like
we have time for one more question um so
the last question is are you able to to
provide demo for cyto sync 1,000
equipment oh yes we are happy to provide
the demo and we also giving the reagents
initial testing if you want to do in
your lab as a um beta tester so you can
test them and once you like then we can
come and provide the cyto equipment demo
along with the reagents so definitely we
allow to provide you demo of the
equipment perfect well thank you thank
you Dr DOA Patel do you have any final
comments for our
audience so thank you
everyone and please feel free to reach
out J script is always there to support
you wonderful thank you again Dr DOA
fatel for your time today and your
important research uh before we go I'd
like to thank the audience for joining
us today and for their interesting
questions uh I'd also like to thank our
sponsors uh for to spons sporing today's
webinar uh J script uh being our sponsor
uh questions we did not have time for
today and those submitted during the on
demand period will be addressed by the
speaker via the contact information you
provided at the time of
registration uh this webcast can be
viewed on demand for two years uh and
labroots will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time
goodbye